alors merci isabelle bonjour à toutes et
à tous je voudrais répondre à la
question qui a été posée par
l'agriculteur en lui demandant de bien
vouloir excuser
ma réponse plus généraliste parce qu'au
fond la question qui pose en tant
qu'agriculteur c'est une question
d'entrepreneurs l'agriculteur est un
entrepreneur c'est un producteur et je
pense que nous avons besoin dans
l'avenir pour être plus heureux puisque
c'est sa question dans les entreprises
dans l'emploi créé plus d'emplois nous
avons besoin d'un transfert massif
massif des charges qui pèsent sur la
production pour transférer ses charges
vers la consommation
c'est ce que le président nicolas
sarkozy avait fait lorsqu'il était à
l'elysée
la conséquence d'une telle décision
permettait de réduire les prix de tout
ce qui est fabriqué en france de réduire
les prix de revient donc de ne pas
augmenter les prix de vente et en même
temps de permettre à notre modèle
français d'être financés sur tout ce qui
est fabriqué à l'extérieur tout ce qui
nous vient notamment des produits des
pays en low cost et donc je crois qu'une
des solutions ça sera d'ailleurs au
coeur du projet n'est ce pas eric woerth
ce sera aussi un débat c'est le
transfert des charges qui pèsent sur la
production sur toutes les heures
travaillées en france pour les
transférer sur les produits qui nous
viennent de l'étranger qui sont
fabriqués à l'étranger
et quand je dis ça je ne dis pas
uniquement par rapport au projet aux
produits qui sont extérieurs à l'europe
mais même à l'intérieur de l'europe nous
avons une concurrence nous avons du
dumping à l'intérieur de l'europe ne
pouvons pas continuer à voir une
différence des prix de revient aussi
importante entre ce qui est fabriqué en
france et ce qui est fabriqué dans
d'autres pays européens
donc monsieur hollande a fait un mea
culpa en ayant cassé ce que nous avions
fait il faudra en tirer les conséquences
moins de charges sur les produits
français c'est beaucoup plus d'emplois
ici en france et par voie de conséquence
pour les agriculteurs et tous les autres
beaucoup plus de bonheur dont beaucoup
plus de travail et dans nos entreprises
et en réaffirmant
fermement que le lieu où l'emploi se
créer c'est l'entreprise ce ne sont pas
les administrations quant à nos jeunes
l'avenir pour nos jeunes il est dans les
entreprises l'alternance en entreprise
ça marche les jeunes dans le service
public ça fait des chômeurs merci